what up reject nation we are here today to watch
moon night episode 3 press ladies and gentlemen we
got Coy Jandreau with us back follow him on tick
tock for a whole bunch of videos he does about all
kinds of things it's great stuff right Coy it's
great stuff long form youtube short form tik tok
yeah hey hey guys full length watch long as we
sync up with the time code for moon i aware john
they're over at our patreon page go over there
sync up with the time code we also got a bunch
of other shows thanks to everyone who's become a
superject it means a ton but if you can't do that
at least leave a like that helps us out in the
algorithm and leave your thoughts down below what
you thought about this episode lastly we should
thank who we should thank the boys at prepper for
editing down the highlights all right guys i think
we're ready to hop into this aren't we caught so
three very excited all right i've included both of
you you guys happy i feel incredibly happy shut up
and then i i found him with the scarab
living 20 minutes from our old place
he's probably going to get himself
killed running around cairo
that's why you look so unhappy to be going home
i love her hair bootleg passport factory more
company let you teach you how to do all of this
the man indulged you you think his dig sites were
any place for a child archaeology one big mess
of obsessive bookworm i just put together who
she is in what sense we'll talk later okay
call me sentimental but i worry about you
have a good trip love
what a great scene
hope we see her again for comic readers i think
she might be the daughter of the scientist who
was digging up that bushmaster kills in the
comments oh that's interesting i like that
yeah we've all we've all read there let me consult
john he's a common expert and if you're already
watching this you already seen the episodes they
might have already clarified that just the theory
here i'll expect isn't cairo is tracking us i know
she's here all it took was a white man a fighter
a white man with a compass of gold we get [ __
] done guys you're never gonna find hero really
oh wow
oh okay dancing we're fighting we're gonna do
keep Khonshu's name
i love the difference in
physicality between the two
i know it's time to taunt i seen
this guy before mark don't do it mark
oh that is so awesome so we stay
with our one lead well i'm alive
where are you taking me you are the airport
he said why are you acting like a foreigner
yeah because stephen could speak the language
or was it jake for a minute
let me talk to you for a second
just avoid all mirrors mark
real born identity vibe to this
absolutely the mark identity
we need the info
oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god stephen
what did you do i swear that wasn't me
where's it
take him to the ledge he's just a kid he'll
talk jake locklear is a cab driver in egypt
he speaks the language
okay oh yep damn you could have stopped
him mark you got guts kid the signal for
an audience with the gods is to risk their
wrath but what's the worst that could happen
anger them enough and they'll imprison me in stone
you have any good ideas ever i have a bad one
can't you i've got some hero's head off
could you eat mr harold
what are you doing no sending the guns
a signal they can't ignore he clips it
get a way to make the news
our case against arrow must be indisputable
aren't you coming with oh i'll be there
a lot of interesting use of waters here mm-hmm and
the conscious appearing very like disorientingly
you've been banished once for nearly exposing us
honshu but manipulate the sky again and we will
imprison you in stone bear me your self-righteous
threat we simply trust our avatars to carry out
our purposes without calling undue attention
to ourselves not like some of us avatars are
not enough that's so good speak your purpose
i call for judgment against arthur harrow
with charges conspiracy to release
amit that's a heavy accusation
just go a few miles if i just just look left
oh [ __ ] as i see by the presence of conscious
current makeshift avatar of our meeting must be
nefarious you know exactly why we are here this
is a man who literally does not know his own
name i have no idea how many personalities
he must possess the man is clearly insane
whoa we will not tolerate violence in this chamber
we'll just let it happen outside are you unwell
oh no oh stephen grant this is about how dangerous
he is if you would just listen for a second he has
committed no offense this matter is concluded
check his tattoo out i feel like we just watched
like a 10-minute tragic play in a shakespearean
set yeah exactly a majority named senfo
he was tasked with recording the location of the
tomb in case the gods ever changed their minds
and decided to show mercy his sarcophagus
was stolen and sold on the black market
you might want to start there maybe it's back at
the fast-forward episode how are you doing here
you should be here why because my name pisses
off a few people in cairo who cares it's not the
locals that i'm worried about come with me i'll
help you find what you need kind of a creep caught
you a little bit just so you know i'm not here to
help you i'm here for me and for everyone else who
have died of horror success if they get back
together is it a polyamorous relationship yeah
multiple personalities don't you do anything
you do anything with stephen i'm a no
ah egyptian red fair everyone loves a good joust
right this way thank you marvel's the knights i'm
looking forward to seeing you after madrid i'm
sure you two will have a lot to tell magikarp
yes they mentioned something we know references
no he gets private lessons by the best
in his backyard oh god this is
my husband brufino yes meet you
why such interest in senpu in particular oh
actually our purchases sorry i'd like to hear from
your husband if you don't mind but i think i just
would love to take a look feel free great yeah
okay rodrigo santoro is an [ __ ] there's no
location indicates it because the information
has to be unlocked it's coded okay will you give
me a minute i just i gotta talk to stephen just
he just needs a couple of minutes in
there alone he's he's he's praying
like this yeah now if you match those
stars up with the other piece over there
and put it all together it should make
a starch hey what are you doing whoa
that's interesting it appears we have
a concerned third party yeah get up
of course that's an [ __ ] you keep thinking
that distance will prevent the wounds from
your father's murder from reopening
your husband doesn't tell you the truth
you don't tell her because you know that if you
do she'll see you exactly as you see yourself
what are you waiting for he's gone where is he
here comes moon cape
nice
buy me some time back in
whoa
nice work
let him do his thing
awesome
give me the body mark
oh that's cool
that's it timeout guys let's all calm down yeah
we're all worked up let's all just not
chill that f out and talk for a second
boy
nice
i love the companion pieces to his moons
for love
into the mist there are parts of us fighting
there might be a bet afflicts batman
acrobatics and brutal like punch
downs what was harrah talking about
what do you mean he said i had a right to know
i have no idea i have herpes i think he killed
her dad we need stephen he understands all of
this i really think it's worth giving him a shot
i summon the guards you summon the worm
it's okay just let go i don't have time
you might need that mirror well now he needs it
for mirror purposes all right go ahead you're in
cheers thanks a lot
cool nice master class with oscar is
[ __ ] incredible they came up with a way
to get about using the sun and the stars
it's french
oh my god she's falling for him we should be able
to triangulate the stars into coordinates right
unless we know exactly what the sky looked like on
that date we're buggered i remember that night ah
i was the one who made james
cameron change the titanic stars
he would have fit on that door though it will
come at a cost and i cannot do it alone are
you gonna get trapped in stone for that i
mean it's kind of a big deal do what i do
the tva is not gonna be happy about this
wow
wow before all that pollution
great transition i don't know
how much longer i can do this
can't you and in the end he left us no choice
he's tethered to this place you saw culture
how's it feel i'm going to do what you could
not then when it's finished i want you to
remember one thing your torment forged me i owe
my victory to you goddamn wow hell yeah i want a
dense episode there was so much death dense are
we talking about eternals whoa guys i mean there
was a lot of non-interference from the gods so
we could be it's true are we still doing your
credit joke and we're not doing the credit show
we gotta do the credit show i do like that they
change up the credits yeah every episode and they
also change up the music too i'm really curious
we're getting jake now that we have a mysterious
third identity do you think you can buy a little
conscious statue within a week oh yeah that's
coming merch i also like that mr knight is now
just representative of the other identities moon
knight they can kind of play with that to make him
less of a wasn't a punchline but it was a joke
in how he was used and now they can evolve that
and that's what i was hoping they'd do with them
well just in that moment alone steven's necessity
really came into the fold this time yeah and mr
knight was a necessity because the control i don't
think there's a post-credits scene probably my
post-credit scene but we should wait efficiency
okay well did you guys like it i liked it i had
a great time part of me was a little worried
that maybe we would get into the middle and it
would start to sag but it did not it had one of
the crazier fight scenes i think we've seen in
a disney plus show many stabbings i also was a
little worried that it was moving at such a fever
pace at the top that this the sag metaphor solid
i don't know if it would if i'd get exhausted
by it like i was worried it would either dip or
it'd be overwhelming like too much but somehow
i'm just tired in a good way i do kind of wish
the pacing of this was more like how it was in the
last the first two was definitely a different more
controlled pace well i think the first the last
15 minute 10 to 15 minutes of this episode like
when layla and him are driving and they're talking
and then they go to the sands that that's when i
was like i kind of wish this was a little bit more
of the pacing for the rest of the episode because
they did jam pack it a lot to the point where so
much was just happening he's chasing down people
we don't know exactly who they were chasing down
for 10 minutes i thought we accidentally watched
the wrong thing that came back yeah it says
there's a time jump and then it was like
we're doing a born movie all of a sudden and and
it's so there's it's moving at such a whiplash
pace you have like everything with arthur herrera
going on and then mark spector and then when they
like oh now we're going to meet the gods and we're
dealing with this trial and it was just like boom
boom boom boom boom and then now we're doing
this like me this handsome dude some guys here
with the map i'm like okay this is this is a it's
just it got to the point where i found myself just
paying attention to get information and i wasn't
really affected by it as much like whereas like
the last two really gave me a lot of feels but i
think the last like 15 20 minutes of this episode
really made up for how i was feeling towards the
first half of this i would have preferred seven
episodes and had that be like one and a half
episodes like i would have this one so like i
would have preferred the show been a little longer
overall i mean obviously we don't know how it's
going to land but like that was a lot yeah just
no postcards and i don't post credit it's it's
interesting because i really loved the first two
episodes a lot and this was like i was usually my
out of the three so far this is easily the one i
would rank third out of them all but there's still
a lot to appreciate i'd say i don't know each
apology i don't know the history of it all my most
knowledge comes from indiana jones and the mummy
like and that's all you need my one year in social
studies where i really paid attention because i
like those movies that's about as far as it goes i
would i movies are important movies attention and
history that might inspire you to pay attention
cyrus and anubis it was great any teachers
watching at home bring in that vcr combo
yeah and scroll that in so i i liked getting a lot
of that lord history that's what i mean i think
there's a lot to appreciate there and i think the
set design is really cool the way they've evolved
conch you as well like here was the first time i
really got the sense that this guy a little bit
twisted and how he's like i really want that lady
you get a sense of actual care from him in this
one especially in that like those last moments the
most consistent factor that i find really strong
is you know oscar isaac interacting with oscar
isaac that to me is is easily the strongest one
we'll get to like our theories and speculation on
what's going on a little bit involving leyla and
perhaps the third personality but one i know we
went out of order you're supposed to be the you're
supposed to be the one that kicks us off kicks
the ball yeah no i mean i i i agree with your
assessment in that this does feel like they kind
of crammed stuff into like it was all interesting
like it's one of those situations where for me
i was like i was interested in everything and
i was pleased with everything that we were
getting but yeah i was like this whole you
know trial seems like it ought to be an expanded
sequence or something like that it's funny because
you have so many reasons to go indiana jones
or the mummy and there are shots that make
me think of that but yeah this was much more of
sort of like a you know foot chase heavy paul
green grassy style thing and i like that stylistic
shift i feel like it's within the personality of
this show and it lends credence to the whole
like we're gonna go a little more hardcore
i i'm a little bit distracted when it is like yeah
they're throwing down on harsher choreography that
still has no blood in it yeah you know so there
is we can have blood as long as it's a cut to
the blood come out it's weird it was more
effective to me in the first episode when you have
uh stephen black out and then come
back with the blood all over the uh
yeah and it's like you know obviously the
trade-off is you get the blood because you
don't get the violence in that situation but you
know i mean that's just a little thing that did
kind of stick out at me as i'm curious to see how
the mcu going forward especially in these shows
will bridge that gap because i don't think they've
fully managed it here the character stuff uh was
really great and from the last episode i
remember us being like i don't know really
what if i wanted to see behind the curtain of
arthur harrow with you know his sinister intent
the way he drains that homeless guy but i thought
the way they brought it back around with him
in this episode with his scenes like it
brought it back to that place of authentic
pathos that comes from him that whole monologue
he gives at the end about like you know if this
mission i'm on you know i owe my conviction
and you know the strength and the burden to you
like i thought that brought him back to a pretty
interesting spot and it helped to alleviate the
sort of repetitive structure that this would have
in the sense that you have mark and layla you know
scrambling to get somewhere and they do and then
hey here comes arthur harrow and he's pretty chill
about it and he's in control and that happens
you know a few times but i thought that when
they really settled into scenes that was when the
episode would sing i totally agree with the arthur
harris stuff i'm back to being 100 interested
and immersed in his character and ethanol is
crushing this very unlikable likable charming
like every action he's doing is impossibly evil
but he's so charismatic and interesting you're
like tell me more about your weird crazy girl
so that's like really impressive work and
also i don't know have ever seen work with
a did study quite like what oscar isaac's doing
because not only do we see visual transformations
with just like eyebrow use and all those things
from one personality to another but when he's
taken over by khanshu and the voice of kontru
feels like it's bursting out of him and he's
like getting exhausted by like being overwhelmed
by this voice that's another complete entity and
another complete acting style the work in this is
insane and laila we got that whole opening scene
where we hadn't really had a lot of time with
layla one-on-one it was really smart to open with
that endear us to her that way we're more invested
in their relationship throughout this episode so
if you only know mark and stephen you don't
really worry about leila's relationship
by the end we're like man layla's falling
for steven and falling out of love with mark
at the same time and now we care about leila
because of that one eight-minute scene so the
structure worked for me but if this episode was an
hour and a half or if this was spread across two i
would have preferred it just because i do feel
like when you eat a sandwich that has too many
toppings some bites are more delicious than others
and there were moments in this that felt like a
too salty bite and i wanted the bites to be spread
out it's a really great sort of great medicine
in this moment that's like a perfect matter
yeah that's right this episode too many too many
toppings my sandwich yeah also i'm hungry i'm sure
there's going to be a lot of temperature hungry
i'm sure there's a lot of people who probably like
really other people like this is their favorite
and it's totally fine yeah i think there's a
lot to appreciate i think the action was cool
i i prefer more of the close-ups on moon knight
when he's fighting because sometimes he's moving
about way too fast for me like when he got to the
roof i'm like what the [ __ ] he was just there
like a second ago i also think this would have
been a really hard script to direct because i
imagine muhammad looked at the script and
went okay we're gonna cover this today
the sheer volume of what this episode needed to do
because we haven't seen any shooting conversation
and like we haven't seen where this goes and what
they had to connect from blank to blank to but
i can't imagine this was not not intimidating
no so like it's a really impressive feat from
the actor's standpoint director's standpoint
production design standpoint costume design
standpoint one of my favorite scenes of this
whole series so far is what they just did at
the end with konchu and mr knight literally
going back through time but i can't imagine
looking at the script starting with layla and
ending with that being like this is an episode
of television it feels like it was also quite
the bite to take when looking at a six episode
series which makes me really intrigued what
four five and six are because if this was two
three what is the rest of the show i haven't lost
faith in it because normally with these shows i'm
like okay episode one and two were kind of
slow but three's when it gets good yeah so
it's kind of an interesting effect when you're
like yeah through is okay but one and two regret
so it's like it makes you still like heavily
invested i'm like a a b plus so far like it's
still high for me but it was just a slight and
that was just overwhelm which a lot of people
also like this is gonna i mean i'm sorry to us but
we're a little older like maybe there's the next
generation who's more of the tick tock mindset
where they're like just gonna need stimulants
i need more at all there's a very plausible
reason that like disney making a show that's
this dense might have felt the compulsion
you have this much in an episode because
a lot of people are on their phones when they
watch tv a lot of people are scrolling a lot of
people you can't with this episode so maybe there
is something to like when we look back at 60s and
70s movies the pacing is like watching paint dry
for me 80 of the time i struggle this might be us
just getting old and this is the new standard and
we're just seeing it and feeling like overwhelmed
for the first time like i don't know what the
standard operating procedure for content and
like amount in in time is gonna be in
five years but it could just be like world
yeah maybe koi that's maybe that's what it is
i'm saying younger people might enjoy
it more but it's still a b-plus for me
personally it's still like one of the better
marvel shows i think with the fighting it
was interesting i like the close-ups on it
more because that's when it looked the more
real practical yeah there were parts of it i'm
like oh that does feel like ben affleck in the
warehouse fight in certain shots certain moments
when he is pounding on them sometimes though i am
curious why some shots of moon knights of outfit
there are some shots where i'm like i get why that
part looks cgi but why does this other part
look cgi and so i don't really understand the
mechanics i know they do these like behind the
scenes on their disney plus shows i'm curious
to know why some shots are like so overtly
cgi when i would when i doesn't i feel like
doesn't feel like it necessitates it but i and
it pulls me out because i feel like with concho
they've like mastered how to do kanchu in like
broad daylight or at night they know how to really
like mask him shadow him in to the point where
it looks so good and even like the last effects
you know with the with the stars and stuff i
thought it was beautiful the ball that looked
like straight out of the comic it was amazing
to look at mr knight always looks fantastic
but then moon night sometimes i'm going why does
he look so computer at times when i he doesn't
seem like he needs to i like the fight a lot it
definitely like you said more stabby stabby than
most of them stabbing stabbing there we go we've
seen thousands of fights i've never seen a horse
spike fight so i like having a new style
of fight because the comics are able to do
so many different also also it didn't even this
is the highlight of the episode for me and it's
a silly small thing but because of my comic book
love they did the thing here that eternals failed
that you guys know i love eternals i saw you i
knew it was coming up in eternals they made a
movie that felt removed from the mcu but had to go
like remember same to you with a couple lines of
dialogue that for me felt forced and actually like
took me out instead of in this mentions a location
within the mcu in a in a context that makes
sense and it goes hey we're going to keep this
very unique tone the show feels nothing like a
lot of the mcu but because the word mad report
in a sentence that fits in context is said in
the comics that would that would have been bold
like you would have just felt that little like
connectivity and therefore this feels like the
comic version of a shared universe more than the
mcu the mcu feels like the movie shared universe
this feels like reading a comic and hearing like
oh i get it and then flip the page like i thought
that was the perfect delivery for madrid for the
mcu at home you know in the last episode there
was a book that was that had asgard on it and
wakanda you know in the first episode when they
hit that bus the bus had the grc on it which is
the uh thing they mentioned about like monitoring
stuff in uh phase four little details but magic
is yeah you know what i think that what what
my the reason why the emotional effect in my mind
felt like it was moving too fast there was a lot
of new characters in this episode you know yeah
absolutely like it feels like a new setup that's
like did i miss something and i was like replaying
the previous thing on my head like no that's
where i left off like it's just like did i miss
something in a week yeah that is a good point
because it didn't hit me at the time and this
episode gave me part of what i was hoping for last
time which was okay now we're gonna do the mark
with stephen breaking through episode and yeah it
didn't hit me until now but you are dealing with
so many new places and people the whole time to
quickly touch back on that thing that you said
about the fighting i think that too goes against
the theory that this is all in his head or that
there's some kind of alternate reality that we're
experiencing here because the more he teleports
around and the more other people acknowledge that
the more it feels like and even things like the
jackal or her being aware of the suit it seems
like this is a tangible thing that is actually
magical and is actually happening it hit me during
this uh that this has two themes that are like
really kind of cyclical throughout the mcu so even
though it's not like reference heavy it is dealing
with how do we handle preventative crime fighting
and also god's not wanting to interfere
with the follies and squabbles of man those
converge here in a really heavy way and it's
like we had that in civil war with the whole
you know like eyes in the sky kind of thing and
we've i'm watching the shield season seven right
now that's all about the past and hey should we
take the shot in the past if it means preventing
blah blah blah in the future like there's so
much about preventative crime in the mcu and i'm
now also waiting for them to take that one step
further because we have this format to do that
in and i thought you know there were some good
arguments toward that within this episode uh on
display and that was some of the strongest stuff
they did here we don't often talk about the macro
of our world in relation to the mcu but bringing
up preventative crime and something i've been
thinking about a lot in our fiction is obviously
we're living in an age of like needing the moral
compass of heroes and our fiction because our
world feels like it's crumbling at all times and
we're seeing as we get older more and more evil
go unchecked and all of her governments and all
of her formats aren't actually doing any of the
things that we were raised to think they were
to do but we're entering the age of like recording
everything in a very orwellian sense we literally
film everything to the point where there's going
to be a time when the 90s and 80s and earlier
are going to be considered prehistoric because
there isn't going to be an objectivity like i'm
sorry a subjectivity everything is going to be an
objectivity everything is going to be recorded so
it's going to be like this is true this is not but
then very soon thereafter there's going to be a
level of deep fakes and a level of unreality where
we're not going gonna actually know what is real
on record or not because we're already getting
deep fake visual and voices that are almost
photorealistic so we're gonna have this short
window where objectivity is gonna take over
and what's that gonna look like with
preventative prime when everything is so
point shoot true false and what is that gray scale
of morality going to be versus law because so many
laws are so updated with the current structure of
reality that's a great philosophical point because
marvel addresses that in each of their films like
we're saying but we don't look at that in our day
to day like we don't reflect that as much but this
show doing that through something so elevated as
egyptian gods from historic times it's really
interesting to look at how you feel about certain
things how you feel about harrow how you feel
about mark how you feel about stephen in relation
how it affects your day-to-day life of what you
perceive these laws and realities and rules as
that make any sense get that all from from
this one episode just i got that all from life
from life that is a great like societal point of
view i think at its core with the mcu and this
show in particular really focuses on what
its characters is about self-acceptance
that's probably the top theme i think like this
whole thing with mark and stephen is there at odds
with one another and mark clearly doesn't like
himself and feels ashamed steven feeling like he's
not good enough and if you look at all our other
characters in the mcu a lot of times their arc
is learning to be like you know what i am enough
i can do this from me yeah whatever my affliction
might be is actually also part of my strength yeah
and that's so comic book-y like that's one of the
things i like about comic books is your weakness
is often your strength and the things that make
you unique or the thing that makes you strong
and i mean and i think in all of our lives once
we accepted more of our weird [ __ ] we became
better at our jobs and our lives and our personal
lives and our relationships and i think that the
marvel characters are very good at going like
hey x-men what makes you a freak is your
strength hey spider-man that like bubble ball
and i think moon knight accepting that steven is
the strength in some circumstances and mark is the
strength in others when mark literally
kills people in steven's little dweeb
those strengths are really incredible to have with
two characters competing for a body i do gotta
say steven did kind of annoy me a little bit when
mark was fighting off those yeah yeah that steven
was like interfering yeah let go and i'm like
dude what are you doing there's the one time i
got i know some people are back and forth that
stephen oh is he an annoying character or not a
lot of people actually like fight about that i've
seen in the comments i don't find him annoying i
like him a lot i love him i actually like him
more than mark i think he's a much more amusing
personality than mark like mark is i don't know
getting more mark in this episode i enjoyed him
i think oscar isaac does a great job but let's
face it just care his portrayal is like it's a
little bit more straightforward yeah it's about
what you'd expect from her that's a hammer and and
steven's uh more of a fine-tooth comb like they're
different skill sets no yeah a thousand percent
i think that's what works best with mark is when
he's interacting with stephen is the complement of
the personalities right that's why i love those
scenes so much is because of that but when you
don't have like mark really interacting with
steven or konshu for that matter i don't find
mark anywhere near as engaging as i do find
steven particularly although whenever he is
donning moon done i'm like hell yeah let's go moon
night that's great now we gotta talk really quick
a couple of theories and i want to turn off the
video now in case just a couple of theories here
one jake locklead a cab driver personality who's
more of like the guy on the st it would stand to
reason that it could be jake lockery as that third
personality jake lockley is more of like the dude
who goes on the streets gathers information and
whatnot you know walks amongst the people and
so i could see him being like yeah he's he's out
and about and this is like in the daylight because
i was like a little bit stricken by oh wow mark's
just out there in the date like messing people up
on rooftops right now okay cool so i could see it
being jake lockley i think jake might be our lead
for the last third i think jake might come in at
the that'd be surprising well think about how like
we talked about how she doesn't really know mark
steven doesn't feel like he has a lot of history
we don't know the stuff of the steven and his mom
and the later gators stuff all those things and
then these blips first introduce the idea of there
being someone else what if these two are in jake's
head true it's interesting because mark brought up
a point about like i thought i was fine for like
the last few years but only recently i started
breaking so it seems like mark has been aware of
his other personalities for a while which would
be comic accurate but then he suppressed them to
the point where they forgot yeah or like or like
steven grant forgot about mark and what's time
perception when you're trapped in the mirror and
like how long is anything for another personality
so i think that could be the case with layla
it seems like that she would be the daughter
of because in the comic around the time before
mark's when mark smacker's just mercenary and
then there's a guy and the lemire small would
run they paint him to look like sam neil
from jurassic park he gets killed i don't think
that character was layla but i think they would
adopt her to be here that would probably be why
yeah mark is like i feel guilty shut up maybe
she doesn't know he was involved yeah i think he
killed sam neil you think so yeah i think mark
killed her dad i think i feel like you'd be on
the same mission but maybe i think he killed him i
think that's what harrow's holding i think harrah
knows or or he's would they go that far or maybe
he's somehow responsible in in a direct way or
or maybe he wasn't able to save him or something
like that i do think that's what i'm saying he
was part of he was like they're what it happened
i feel like it would be in the mask i feel like it
would be an interesting challenge if they actually
let him be the one who did it because then what
would the conversation be about her loving stephen
and not mark yeah because mark killed her dad but
steven didn't same body though how do you forgive
the body of a man that's a there's a philly
question if you've got multiple personalities
people who date people with the
idea yeah like i said polyamory
gets complex you know you're polyamory in a
one-stop shop mark specter stephen grant blockley
they're different too like they'd be like a
gentle lover and mark would probably be more
aggressive one might be subservient it might
be a dom they probably have different kinks
you know that body is you would be like
oh i don't know what to do right now
i think stephen has got all that geeky like
stamina and mark's got too much ptsd where
he's actually the struggle i think stephen better
than mark and no but jake jake cleans them oh jake
handles this jake's man oh yeah he knows what he's
doing that's why you need jake the second third of
the show third of the show the second half of
the show should be like eyes wide shut in egypt
gotta send this to disney let them know what
we want make it happen you know when you're
tired and i'm tired we perform at two very
different energy levels it's fascinating
you're still remarkably sharp i go
up and up in order to not fall asleep
it's impressive i wish i had some food here
guys sandwiches overstuffed what'd you think
leave your thoughts down below hey we'll
catch you guys soon check us out patreon